déjà vainqueur il ya deux ans le belge
maxime authom s'impose une nouvelle fois
au tournoi future de feucherolles opposé
en finale au français josselin ouanna
illustre tombeur de marat safin à roland
garros en 2009 le louviérois remporte la
rencontre 7-6 7/5 légèrement blessé
ouanna a tenu à disputer la finale mais
a clairement souffert dans ses
déplacements savait qu'il avait un peu
mal à la cuisse donc j'essaye de le
faire bouger mais frappait tellement
fort que des fois je voulais juste la
mettre dedans et serait pas assez bon
les coûts qui l'attend et il en a mis
beaucoup de temps donc c'est vrai que
c'était pas facile même même blessé donc
j'essaye d'être solide et bon à la fin
il a un peu craqué que les derniers jeux
étaient un peu plus facile quoi très
grand jour c'est toujours pour gagner
même si je sais que les futures c'est
quand même le plus petit tournoi jeudi
raté paix maintenant et des très bons
joueurs on sait jamais facile de les
gagner je suis quand même très content
d'avoir gagné aujourd'hui vainqueur pour
la deuxième fois en trois participations
maxime authom gagne 13 places au
classement atp pour être désormais 300
8e joueur mondial josselin ouanna et lui
271e